wow e tv labirinto oggi faremo un escape
room horror estremo nella casa del
pagliaccio cattivo l'astronomia gente
volete vedere altre che showroom horror
video raggiunge i 10 mila mi piace fare
un'altra i promo paurosa mettetevi
comodi prende tifo carli e che segua
questo è l'entrata della casa del
pagliaccio pauroso b riconosce il mio
outfit è di un personaggio famoso
vediamo chi reso indovinare chi è tra
nelle orecchie quelli li ho messi io
oggi gli orecchini abbiamo che io adoro
ora entriamo seguito dalla bocca del
pagliaccio
siamo stati rinchiusi nel carnevale
abbandonato da un pagliaccio malvagio
permettere di trovare un modo di fuga
forse meglio non entrare allora partite
vediamo perché si è rotto sicuramente
l'ha fatto lui è vitale già morto se il
palloncino rosso vuol dire che può
vicino il pagliaccio troviamo molto
trentino rotto il palloncino dobbiamo
seguirlo attento ti stai buttato giù
sono ancora un rumore pauroso per
evitare che ha buttato giù praticamente
tipo una gola con dei denti aiuto che
abbiamo vicino delle varie palloncini ma
possiamo saltare sui palloncini
penso che sia l'unica strada
non voglio cadere giù arrivo quanto
siamo in alto che paura che fa questa
volata sotto tela bianca
primo sfracella mento sto arrivando
magari ti aspetto potere della luna
superare questo stato
mancini che non copino ha detto ok che
posso farcela resto locale alla cantante
di caldaia dai molto attento per me
l'importante è non incontrare il
pagliare bruciamo quante volte destra
jellato già vitale che non ci sono le
mani di it che nessuno del pagliaccio
aiuto se non mi seguite ancora finita
che non mi raccomando andate a seguirmi
il nome a di testori tv ha fatto locale
caldaia un po strano dai molto attento
leone porta dice cosa c'è queste sono le
mani di it che figo grande abilità di
salto non ha comunque no non è molto
figo temi e di fretta si no puntiamo
quante volte si è sfracellato anita
aiuto aiuto aiuto
ok ai vari ma la novità
tra questi rumori sono super strani
sembra tipo del vapore voglio cambiare è
tanta da dove esce questo lavoro ma
dobbiamo andare ad era forse dobbiamo
salire su questi dubbi veli sempre più
in alto una scala meglio non guardare
giù mamma mia
diventa super difficile adesso guarda
siamo arrivati all'ultimo tubo via nova
bisogna tenere l'equilibrio ma da quanto
siamo in alto aiuto io odio le altezze
vi parlato bene mura
alla fine la juke e 6 siamo vicini sono
fatta ok dove dobbiamo andare qui e
guarda un po che scolano ecco anche il
pagliaccio vuole far mio bettin e allora
qui c'è una scala non marito della donna
è o perché sta salendo contratto
sono uscito wow le giostre del
pagliaccio un castello posso sentire un
trauma che sta ridendo fanno che dovevo
mai la sua strada su una ruota
panoramica dobbiamo andare nella ruota
forse dobbiamo salire da qui e saltare
fuori quindi attento il paio con quello
che poi scappa scappa scappa ma che ha
preso io sono riuscito a scappare
tante 1 sulla ruota vedi qui scappa dopo
gruppo
[Musica]
lasciate un mi piace per portarmi
fortuna nel palazzo allora io cambio
direzione dove li su questa qui wow che
bello ha avuto bel panorama
anche se ho un po di paura di cadere e
arrivando a livello che per paura dove
dobbiamo andare qui guarda brava pensavo
di cadere giù
allora qui portato questa parte invece
abbiamo le montagne russe o no abbiamo
salire sulle montagne russe ma speriamo
abbiamo tante che non appaia il
pagliaccio nuovamente fare molta
attenzione perché è facile cadere da qui
ok nuovamente i palazzi piano quel punto
il fiuminata si sta aspettando sotto
meglio non cadere noi infatti sappiamo
sopra male non stare qua sopra una via
d'uscita joo cho ho mai a quella torre
altissima
ci dobbiamo sedere forza io non sono
riuscito a 79 61 a fianco a tema
[Musica]
sta tornando ad esso va be ma che
avventura incredibile room o no alta e
trappole guarda con una sento a teatro
no forse devi riuscire a saltare devi
saltare sull'ultima troppo presto dice
l'ho fatto non ti farò mai una
bravissima a un altro ancora felice o no
la ghigliottina aiuto sono anch'io come
siamo la volta di fila capirà ok
rifate uscita devo riuscire a fare il
giusto quest'ultima è velocissimo per sé
riuscito a passare ecco vitale
ce la farà ce la farà si valuta di
parlare per ultima
[Musica]
dobbiamo passare evitando queste mega
troppo legata svolto
ho passato la prima non sono anch'io
come non ci credo ce l'ho fatta e vitale
toys premi paesino per te crotone vita
uno è fatta ricarige l'ha fatta
veramente si è sfracellato 10.000 volte
ma sta diventando sempre più diffuso
lì ci sono dei testi e delle rose
strattonò che cos'è un portale c'è solo
un modo per scoprirlo dobbiamo entrare
nel portale
mi sembra un drago pronti via
guarda c'è un ponte di legno gucci anche
un vulcano delle ossa
bisogna stare un po attenti che sono
sicura che cadrò qua aiuto ok piano
affrontarci un terremoto sta muovendo
tutto il vulcano mista che sta per
lottare è meglio che ci sbrighiamo
dobbiamo andare adesso altri portali
cioè attenta perché qui c'è solo le
fiamme se ci sei riuscita
no non siano portati una volta 25 la
vita le ho fatto io ma qua a siena
anch'io sono caduto o causano google
translate per tradurre dall'inglese
perché l'inglese dice haifa e batteri ma
frequente lo traduci parola per parola a
e vuol dire alto è five vuol dire 5
quindi hanno tradotto da più alto cina
ecco perché è sempre meglio lasciare
l'inglese nel gioco anche se guardate
magari serie tv cartoni animati film
lasciati l'inglese mettete i sottotitoli
in inglese e in italiano così imparerete
zeneli viabilità nord le cose
salta stai attento che bello che ormai
che deve fare quando ci prendiamo la
vera ok sono arrivato fin qua devo
farcela leiber ci sei quasi mi stanno
dando google e il card ok ci siamo quasi
devi arrivare aquino il castello o no e
ancora 4 dove devo saltare ha detto
hanno piano piano devo capire quindi un
po di corsa eccolo ok bravi dai posso
farcela testa fuori parlo lo guardano
solo lì bravo attiva a correre però un
altro portale
wow queste clip room e filippo mano
bellissima c'è scritto questo fuoco
brutti si farà saltare in alto
ho capito guarda ti adoro di barriera
tra tutti è che papà
sta diventando sempre più difficile
[Musica]
no ok borioso e dopo avere un pochettino
guarda il vulcano è enorme e tutto da
sopra però di non cadere l'ultimo ok
prossimo equa tra sfracellato ok
ricordiamoci che il fuoco ed hanno fatto
[Musica]
sì vabbè io mi sono bloccata con barche
fatti temporale sotto volando dove si
sogna andare a detta dello stesso
bisogna andare nel vulcano dentro vi
siano coni che bisognava andare
ecco vita ne ha ma siamo riusciti siamo
riusciti ad uscire secondo me non è
ancora finita guardate e ancora il
pagliaccio
la mostra spaventoso ma stiamo ancora
intrappolati
dobbiamo entrare nella casa del manuzzi
che paura o no guarda tenta di laser ma
sta diventando così piccoli e visto che
diventa tutto in una forma super diversa
davanti ai più si distorce tutto vuole
farci tipo un'illusione ottica
non capisco si sta rimpicciolendo si sta
ingrandendo cosa a super distorta non
risco capitale ne mancano solo due posso
farcela aiuto una prova abbastanza wow e
tv labirinto sugli specchi le trappole
le porte misteriosissimo santoro troppo
ti vede che la casa del pagliata stiamo
piano piano ma quale porta dobbiamo
scegliere
spero che sia la porta giusta che non ci
sei quasi da quella parte bravi ok
entriamo in questa porta misteriosà se
siamo qui e ti poni latere ottica ma
capisco ma non puoi anche fare troppo
tempo sorpresa di nuovo perché sono caso
l'ottimo wow appena sembra di essere in
un la perché abbiano fatto a questa
parte
no non ce la fa ma ti aiuto io tratte a
questa casa
[Musica]
bravissimo mia lingua originale perché
porta 10 mila volte
ma che cos'è non potete non mi fido
molto a salire 4 presidente paolo
lantero allo stesso tempo bisogna
continuare a correre
ci sono gli ostacoli ovviamente o no
un'idea
no non mi pare ok forte ho capito
bisogna fare fino all'ultimo e poi
saltare due salti o che i due stati due
bravo e velocità ok vediamo se riesco
anche in questo con due salti il super
difficile dire avvicinare il più
possibile puoi fare due salti ok sono
vicine al più possibilisti metal tirava
note le ore al 30 30 si si si avvicina
dio vicino il più possibile
non così tanto però non ci credo sì
siamo sfracellasi 10 milioni di volte
anche aiutato vitale salviamo subito o
se siamo o no non mi dire che un'altra
cosa tu per di pi quintana russe
forse abbiamo quasi finito allora
dobbiamo salire sulle montagne siano
queste montagne russe notte ma io sono
salito o no perché sono da solo
aiuto guarda talento per la bellissima
prova benson stupende che gigante
attento all'improvviso finiscono le
montagne russe hd per terra come così
ok ci credo sono più e stato un giro
accidentato se non col pittore il
medagliere buoni ce l'abbiamo fatta
brevi aveva tagliare iniziati a scappare
dal pagliaccio e tutto bellissimi
lunghissima difficilissima non aveva
lasciato un bel mi piace rovi lasciavo
qua quattro case linee su cui cliccare
per vedere in altre altri video in casa
su quella che preferite
buona visione